- I'm ready to see my old-ass self.
Shit, let's see it.
(zen music)
- I've always liked old people.
Like I've just thought
old men are cool looking
so I'm hoping like I'm
a cool-looking old man.
But I could also see myself being like
a creepy-looking old man.
- I take care of myself, I
work out, I ride my bike a lot.
- I smoke cigarettes daily.
Sometimes it can be anywhere from like
five to 15, it really just
depends on the mood I'm in
and how much I got going on.
- I know my family and we
pretty much look the same.
I don't think I'm gonna age much.
- I'm a little scared,
I'm a little worried,
I'm a little nervous.
- My face is slimmer, I think too,
which is interesting.
- OK, alright, not that different really.
The bags under my eyes have gotten
a little bigger, my face is
like sagging a little more.
- Yeah, the face seems to be thinning out
a little bit in 10 years from now.
- And I'm starting to look a little old.
- I don't know, it's
mostly under the eyes,
that it's really increasing
and I'm getting more
like crows feet kind of things over here.
- OK, now I'm starting
to see some sort of more
sorta lines here in the cheeks.
- Oo, I think I am in the grave
already actually (chuckles).
I look dead.
- I look old, but I look healthy.
I look like a healthy old guy.
- I'm seeing a lot more like lines
in my face here, the eyes, like around
the eyes look a little just aged.
- This is probably from looking at
computers all of my life,
looking at a lot of screens.
- Those eyes have seen things.
- Yeah, I mean, it's just weird.
It's so weird to see
this photo and just like
almost like see yourself as a grandfather
or like a great-grandfather.
It's wild, man, I mean,
it definitely makes me appreciate the now.
75 as a smoker, you're looking like
you're like picking out
the casket to be honest.
Like it's pretty bad.
Yeah, man, this is a wakeup call for sure.
- We have one time to do this life.
We have one body.
We have to take care of ourselves.
- I look at this photo and I go,
"That guy doesn't look
like he feels good."
- When you're young, you feel like
you're invincible, but
being pushed in the face
with this image of
myself way down the road
in my life reminds me
like everything I do today
is gonna have an effect
on me later and I need to
be fucking careful with
what I put in my body,
how I treat my body because I want to
live to a ripe old age.
- I mean, I need to find a man now 'cause
if I'm looking around for
a man looking like this,
it ain't gonna happen.